your fans are obsessed your fans are
maniacal they're driven and you get
asked to sign a lot of breasts now
that's something that rock stars are
usually they usually just reserved for
rock stars but you asked to sign breasts
and I'm told that you're happy to do it
I should say I do not ask to sign
breasts that would be very very
offensive yeah in this day and age ma'am
can I just sign your boobie right it's
not gonna work I only do it when they
offer their boobie up to me right right
and then they have opened the Pandora's
box if you will of their boobie yeah but
you know it's not something you slap -
and do it's a Sharpie it's a very
specific pen it reacts with the skin's
oils very specifically and sometimes is
prone to skip and then you've ruined
your entire signature sure if you go
back and try and fill it in you can tell
that that's what you did yeah
so it's important to apply surface
tension to the situation
and I'm a lefty and it's it works best
if if I am the guide to apply the
surface tension to the boob the left
boob is my favorite one is that gives me
full access from the right side and
normally you apply pressure below the
nipple so that it's now you go right
ahead like if I was gonna give you go
that way to beat I would apply pressure
here yeah so that this would be a baby
surface tension there
[Applause]
wardrobe
so boy let me just say I'm also very
glad that I was never a baseball player
sign in that round [ __ ] it's kind of I
mean you don't need to put the surface
tension on while you're talking to me
would you like me to demonstrate how I
use my throw rice Sharpie doesn't say
yeah yeah applying proper surface to
Center Lord let me let me know if you
feel any lumps it's nothing I take
lightly no no clearly you've gone to
engineering school you've given this a
lot of thought yeah but that that is
right where the halter top traffic will
be so in the summer time no one's gonna
see it or you do that for workplace no
because their favorite thing is to go
have you seen
you